hey youtubers it's Charlie this is gonna
be my flash episode 3 video a lot of
groundwork being laid for legends of
tomorrow that we'll talk about once we
get to spoilers so as you I'll just quit
and say that now careful for spoilers if
you haven't seen the episode yet what
we'll do is just start with top 5
moments then I'll explain there are some
Easter eggs for Smallville in this
episode which you may have picked up on
just because some of the actors in it
we're also in Smallville and new round
of the reverse flash ring giveaway
starts now all you have to do to enter
is be a subscriber and leave a comment
on this video so here we go starting
with number 5 meet Captain Cold and
golden gliders father played by Michael
Ironside so in the context of the TV
show he's an actual person like they
bring him on in the comics usually the
characters are much older so their
father is a strange like he's a
non-issue he's just floating around
somewhere in the ether or he's dead the
TV show version of the character very
true to the spirit of the comic book
father it's his job to humanize Captain
Cold laying groundwork for legends of
tomorrow for him to be this antihero
because as we've seen him before he's
really closer to being a villain now
they changed things in the comics all
the time during the new 52 though golden
glider is very much a rogue she's every
bit as evil as Captain Cold
alright yeah you know evil is a relative
term but she's as much of an antagonist
as he is in this episode she actually
seems very genuine but do not be
surprised if she totally pulls the rug
out from under cisco actually on to my
number 4 cisco and golden glider is now
the most interesting relationship on the
flash and even though it's not like an
actual relationship a lot of moments
between characters are non-verbal
moments so like the way she touches him
the way he looks at her the way he
rushes in to try and save her before
before they messed things up in the lab
and set the bomb off accidentally if
you're not a big fan of this
relationship stuff don't worry they're
not gonna like beach over the face with
it it's not gonna be a big thing because
Lisa snart isn't gonna be in every
single episode but I just feel like
there's somewhere that cisco has like a
secret picture of her like you know he
had that picture that he got of him in
the canary last season he's he's like a
super fanboy for everybody I feel like
he also has a secret picture of golden
glider in his wallet his awesome is the
Captain Cold scenes word of this week
especially with Michael Ironside being
so amazing at being such a vicious
character I feel like the scenes with
Cisco and golden glider were way more
fun and who else is noticing the theme
of guns when we have rogue episodes
what is it about you and gun Cisco you
should see my nerve collection like
anytime captain cold or the Rogues were
in an episode gun technology is a big
thing visually a big part of her
conversations with Cisco about having a
bad father Leonard taking care of her
also kind of bleeds into the other
storylines too like Barry talking to Joe
about look how I turned out I turned out
this way because you raised me things
could have gone very differently so like
you know Captain Cold
probably would not have been a villain
if his dad wouldn't have been so awful
but you can change that you can make
different choices you don't have to be
defined by your past you see how they're
like delaying groundwork for a big
reveal I think that zooms character is
going to tie into this theme too but the
biggest thing in this episode is really
just setting captain cold up to be a
hero when legends of tomorrow starts so
that is like the bigger store in line
than the zoom storyline it's just that
big themes in episodes apply to all the
characters in all the storylines so of
course on a number three Joe tells iris
that her mother is still alive this is
actually a pretty pretty shocking reveal
her mother franciene was a drug addict
Joe senator rehab after she od'd went
one of many times that she had problems
with drugs like just the last time that
he sent her to rehab she took off and
just disappeared so that explains a lot
of Joe's scenes with Francine like what
do you know what are you doing back here
you don't deserve to be in Iris's life
this is basically gonna be irises big
season long story arc healing her family
season 1 was about Barry trying to heal
his family you know get his father out
of prison save his mother's life season
two gonna be all about fixing irises
family which don't you feel like throws
some more fuel on the fire that is the
theory that zoom is a West either like a
Joe West or he's Wally West I really
rather he beat Wally West because it's
like you know Barry being the child is
like I want to fix my broken family
wouldn't it be amazing if Wally West had
the same thought but he didn't have the
same type of parenting that Barry had so
he turned out bat-like he instead of
becoming a hero he became a villain
that's just a theory about to put on the
Shelf we still don't have enough
evidence yet we haven't got our Wally
West reveal but we did get some
foreshadowing at the beginning of the
episode this scene where Barry is
messing with the beaker when iris calls
him and he spills it if you've never
read the original Barry Allen Silver Age
comics Wally West Was Kid Flash so what
they did is they had Wally go to Barry's
lab where Barry got his powers
originally you know with the the
chemical spilling and getting struck by
lightning and Wally West was involved in
the exact same time of accident and
became Kid Flash he wore a costume just
like Barry's at first until they changed
it and made it yellow and then he only
started wearing the red costume again
after a crisis on Infinite Earths after
after he'd grown up and he took the
mantle of the flash what they've said
about Wally West on the TV show now I
mean we haven't seen him yet obviously
in an episode but they've been referring
to him as Kid Flash so he will be
younger than Grant Gustin on the show
but I don't know how young he'll be
because the actor playing him isn't that
much younger than Grant Gustin in real
life speaking of earth-2 on to number
two Jay Garrick is ready to go home now
using the speed cannon what a catchy
name for the earth to portal so the
funny thing here is just like the
parallel storyline that he and Caitlin
have with Barry and Patty so you know do
they have like that awkward meet-cute
moment where Caitlin's stalling to get
Jay Garrick to stick around longer you
guys can let me know like who do you
think has more chemistry at this point
do you think that Barry and Patty who
are just like dork twins or do you think
that Caitlin and Jay who have slightly
more traditional personalities when the
actor that plays Jay Garrick was talking
about his character like becoming Jay
Garrick he's like I'm trying to bring
this old-world sensibility to the
character from the comics even though in
the TV show he's a much younger
character like you know he's someone in
this like maybe early 30s so whenever
they do these like relationshipy scenes
most of the awkward humor is gonna come
from Caitlin's character with Jay
Garrick and then Barry and Patti just
kind of take that awkward dork energy to
hyper speed but finally on to my number
one WTF Martin Stein flips out and gets
ready to fuse a new firestorm matrix
with the Jay Jackson character and
Harrison wells of earth 2 comes through
the portal let's go with firestorm
version two first that's gonna be the
next episode it's pretty
self-explanatory they find a match for
the firestorm matrix someone that's
compatible so then they fuse and it
helps keep Martin Stein from dying
we can talk most about that next week so
next week will be a heavy firestorm
episode but Harrison wells from earth-2
I saw a lot of you guys freaking out
about this on Twitter so here's the deal
the look on his face here yeah it looks
a little bit evil but earth to Harrison
wells
isn't going to be the exact same
character as
Arsen wells from earth one the reverse
flash Harrison wells he will be working
with the characters Tom Cavanagh is a
series regular he's gonna be in most of
the episodes of the season but he is
just like a super character he's
not evil he's just a super big dick part
of that I think is to make Martin
Stein's seem more likable because right
now he's really short with people he's
just not quite as friendly as some of
the other characters at STAR Labs and I
feel like Tom Cavanaugh the actor in
real life does much better when he's
playing characters that can be somewhat
unlikable he's has a really good job of
making unlikable characters seem really
likable that's one of the hardest things
to do as an actor like you're playing a
character that's really unpleasant but
your job is to make the audience love
you I think you guys are really gonna
like the character this season Tom
Cavanagh is awesome he's even more
awesome when he gets to be like a little
bit evil without actually being evil let
me know in the comments though how far
out do you think we are from a wally
west reveal
I feel like irises mother's gonna be
like okay I was away for 20 years while
I was away I also had this other child
he'll just show up in town and then iris
will have to deal with them like okay
you know I don't know who you are but
you're part of our family now iris just
seems like the type of person who would
be really quick to bring people into the
family even even though she will have
her WTF moment WTF is this brother I
didn't know I had just explained the
really big Smallville Easter Egg they
had it like a really awesome Smallville
joke in the episode when Barry's
introducing himself to Michael Ironside
he says my name is Sam
that's no Maj to Michael Ironside who on
Smallville played General Sam Lane Lois
Lane's father and Lucy lanes father who
was played by Peyton lists who is golden
glider on the TV show so Michael
Ironside was her father on Smallville
he's her father on this show now to both
very terrible dads if you guys didn't
see it I named the reverse flash ring
giveaway winner from last week in my
Star Wars trailer video so just re-watch
that video if you haven't already I'll
put a link in the description
it's just that I'm moving to a new
apartment this week and there was so
much Star Wars stuff so I wasn't able to
get the QA video out so hopefully that
will not be the case this week but I
will be posting a new Gotham video from
this week and new agents of shield but
they'll just be a little bit later this
week than normal
don't worry still posting all the
regular stuff and I will do like a room
tour video of my new apartment like once
I actually get
sure in there while you guys wait for
everything you can click here to watch
the Star Wars trailer again like 15 more
billion times and you can click here for
all my flash and arrow videos thank you
so much for watching everybody let's
high five I'll see you guys tonight